all right we are now live for the AMA
session 4 for July I'm going to take a
look real quick at the sound settings
make sure that we've enough ended up a
little bit so I see there's already a
lot of questions waiting for me and I'm
going to jump into them right away
so the first one is start with Cicero's
on fate and I'm not quite sure but that
doing there but you know yeah that's
what it's a great great work maybe that
came out of some sort of conversation
people are having with each other let me
actually do something with the pop-out
chat let's see if we have everything
that is in fact first one so kind of
interested in things to say to start
with let's look at the next one
Mason asks you've spoken before about
the place of philosophers such as
Derrida not occupying much space in the
history of philosophy in the future what
place do you see alasdair macintyre
occupying in history and that is a good
question
I would say that you know I don't know
that MacIntyre is going to be considered
to be as important as say Aristotle or
Descartes or you know goal but I think
he's gonna certainly remain off they're
closely connected with people these you
know one of the things that's cool about
MacIntyre you can say this about other
thinkers like Heidegger or Hana ranch or
you know Hegel is that they're engaging
with other thinkers and we see through
their eyes what is in these other
people's thoughts and what we might have
missed so I think that that's quite
important but then Mack
has also a lot of really interesting
contributions to make of his own eye
that means going to maid role in my foot
when I first read after virtue I'm back
in graduate school it was one of those
sort of coming home moments where you're
like yeah this this is right this this
actually makes sense I don't buy all of
the narrative and I think I could
quibble with him on this and that but
some of it certainly seems to be totally
on point that was from Mason so dhruv
asks I jumped into Heidegger without
Hegel and Kant and will tackle them
after Heidegger for whom I had a lot of
interest right now what's your advice or
cautions for this route I mean jumping
in high detergent cold without any real
background and philosophy that's
problematic Hegel and Kant aren't the
most important you know or only thinkers
to to consider when it comes to
Heidegger I mean Aristotle would be just
as important Plato would be just as
important Heidegger did quite a few
lectures on both and brings them up
quite a bit it's it's good to know about
Descartes and not just caricatures of
Descartes in order to understand what
Heidegger is reacting against but you
know I think you can you know this
applies really across the board in
philosophy people could ask this well if
I'm gonna redo Augustine you know I
haven't read Cicero yet I know like I've
seen references Cicero quite a bit well
is that okay yeah because what you do is
you read some and then you bounce back I
mean I don't think you should think of
your reading contents like you need to
read all of what Kant says start with
the prolegomena and the groundwork and
then you know come back to Heidegger and
then go from Heidegger back and maybe
read the first critique and that'll take
you a while right and then come back to
Heidegger so you know that's that's what
I would say is probably a good way to go
on it puns and someone who's very
productive will advice you give to
people who struggle in that area
especially someone who has new
responsibilities such elder care child
care
cetera so I would say I look more
productive than I actually am I
there's a lot of things that I set my
hands to that I don't get done when I
want to and it's difficult for somebody
like me to be adequately forgiving
towards oneself for for doing that and
and if you're adding new
responsibilities in you know like like
taking care of an elderly parents or
aunt or uncle that can really draw a lot
and it's not just the consumption of
time and energy
it's the consumption of you might say
head in heart space right I know for me
teaching as much as I do that draws a
lot from me in terms of my own energy
and stuff like that and I would also you
know say taking care of kids similar
sort of thing much of my parenting is of
course at a distance and my kids are now
quite a bit older but that can certainly
consume a lot because especially with
kids because you don't want to lose out
on important times with them so you know
I guess it's all a matter of keeping
things in perspective there's there's
there's no such thing as like index ease
of productivity that apply across the
board to everybody it's all going to be
to some degree relative right so that
what what's productivity for you at this
point in time and your life is not going
to be productivity for you at a
different point you know like when for
myself when it comes to reading I don't
get as much time to read as I would like
these days because I'm busy doing other
stuff right and I can tell myself I need
to spend more time on well there's only
so many hours in the day back at
graduate school and I spend entire days
almost reading you know just alternating
that with making something to eat and
doing some exercise and then going back
to reading again and I felt a lot more
productive but
I think you have to figure out what
you're going to take as your standard
for yourself alright John says how
should cultural or moral relativism and
moral pluralism be distinguished thank
you for your time as always well
relativism is saying it's all relative
right that's that's this is a pretty
easy straightforward or what it's kind
of give no way in the the very names any
sort of relativism has a hard commitment
to saying that there is no such thing as
like a truth per se or moral value per
se it's all going to be relative to
particular groups or communities or
perhaps even individuals or eras
pluralism recognizes that there are you
know multiple legitimate ways of looking
at things but but it being a pluralist
doesn't mean that you have to say
everybody's right you know you can you
can say I'm going to pick and choose and
there will be some places where I have
to decide is it Aristotle or the Stoics
the value of goods other than virtue is
it you know this or that on these points
and so you have to you have to decide
for one or the other but you keep
yourself open to the fact that you you
might not be making the best choice and
you could revise it later on you know
some some examples of good pluralists in
that respect from people like William
James you know alright let's take
another one Gerber curious
thank you for your so much content over
the years my question centers on Lacan
who did he negate most completely Freud
or Co Jeb or the Buddha I don't know
what do you mean by negate I don't know
that that's a particularly useful
question I don't have an answer for that
one all right mark Schmitt is here I'm
always happy to see mark is somebody who
I collaborate with quite a bit this Iran
says what contemporary public Christian
and
Electro's do you most least respect
these days such as David Bentley heart
and he right William Lane Craig I mean I
don't pay much attention to any of them
really quite frankly I you know heart I
was interested in in part early on
because he actually had a decent
Orthodox reading of Vance um and he's
quite and today you know late modern
thought and trying to bring that into
stuff William Lane Craig I don't respect
at all I just think he's kind of a hack
out there who's who's very popular
because he makes apologetics arguments
that other people are attracted to but
that sort of apologetics I have thought
was you know I mean I see why people get
into it because they love to have you
know knock-down drag-out arguments as we
used to call them back in grad school
but they're usually you know they're not
very good you know and that's not the
way that people are actually brought to
any sort of religious perspective that
that's going to stick with them for for
a while and be productive so I don't I
don't have much to say about that you
know I'm not spending an awful lot of
time reading people like that these days
I've been spending way more time the
last couple of years just immersed in
primary texts and most of it from the
history of philosophy as I developed
more and more resources so all right
mark Huff Ling has our culture gone
astray our young people are preoccupied
with celebrity overpriced name-brand
items and spending too much time on
smartphones well if that's the criteria
for how our culture has gone astray then
it has been astray pretty much for
centuries because you will find those
sorts of these kids these days
discourses going all the way back to
ancient Rome
Juvenal satires right and everywhere in
between so I know I don't think that
that's a sign that our culture has gone
astray I think those are those are
things that can be abused but celebrity
has been an issue ever since there's
been any sort of publicity right you see
in
and the Platonic dialogues people are
like hey Protagoras came to town oh
let's go check him out you know there's
already a kind of celebrity involved in
that it gets much more as we have mass
media but you know an interconnected
devices like you know the internet
mobile devices but it's not something
radically new I mean people were
complaining about this back when I was
in college in the 90s and you know TV
was going to destroy my generation and
perhaps that already destroyed the
generation before mine the baby boomers
so I don't I don't think that that's
those are more like symptoms rather than
causes of whatever culture has gone
astray and the other thing I'll say is
our culture has always gone astray you
know there's never been a a wonderful
time when everything made sense that was
always when you look at that look
backwards at that there's always this
nostalgia but it's always [ __ ]
because things were never is great or if
they were great for one person it was
usually at the expense of all sorts of
other people as well
all right William Zen any advice on how
to study psychoanalysis well I would
suppose that it would make sense to
start by reading some Freud you know and
you don't have to like read everything
in its corpus but there are some really
important works that that it would
probably be good to get your hands on
you know get like a Freud reader or
something like that and then you'd start
to read other people in the
psychoanalytic movement which would
include young but also lots of other of
Freud's students and analy's ann's and
people like that and then you know you
would continue further on into more
contemporary stuff you know
psychoanalysis is still an evolving
discipline it doesn't have the cultural
dominance that it used to have in the
past
but it's still out there and people are
still engaging in it the biggest the
biggest obstacle to engaging in
psychoanalysis it turns out primarily to
be cost because if you want to do
analysis you got to go in like every
week at least and oftentimes they don't
take insurance and they'll charge
anywhere up to like you know four
hundred fifty bucks a session so it's
become something more for rich people
than anybody else not like it was in the
fifties where if you said you know
psychotherapy people automatically
thought about psychoanalysis but you
know it's still still there
mark-ass how I'm doing today I'm doing
pretty good I shot some some human
videos this morning continuing on with
what I was doing before stuff for my
classes got this event and then I've got
my philosophy chat for for patreon
supporters coming up a little bit later
today and of course you know on River
West radio we've got episode 17 of the
wisdom of life show airing at 4:00 p.m.
Central that's easy enough to it's a
Google River West radio it'll come up
and you can you can find listen live
things so it's it's a pretty good day so
far and think I'm probably going to take
a walk later on around Milwaukee and
take some more pictures and I'll
probably go down by the river and I
might actually walk along the Hank Aaron
trail which is which is quite beautiful
so you know what else we've got some
good soup that my wife made just last
night that we had for dinner and I'm
gonna have that for lunch once I get off
of here my cat is sleeping just about
six feet from me on her her pile of dog
beds and we had some good news about
about her we took her into the vet
earlier this week and anytime you go to
the vet with an old cat you know it
might be well she's gonna die tomorrow
but no she's she's do actually doing
pretty good for a 17-year old who's
going to turn eighteen before too long
so things are things are go
pretty good hope that all of you are
having a good day Bruce is here as well
another one of my long-term
interlocutors I'm glad to see see him
here as well all right let's take
another question
Joseph asks do I think that hedonism and
asceticism can be reconciled and he's
saying you know stoic and epicurean
thought it depends on what you mean by
reconciled if you mean like brought into
some system where you've got elements of
both yeah sure I mean they already do
have some things in common they both
acknowledge the four cardinal virtues
right they just understand them quite
differently place to go for that by the
way it would be Cicero's on the ends
books one two three four
um but ultimately if what you mean is
can you bring them in one single
coherent system that largely keeps all
the substance and insights of them the
answer is no you got to pick and choose
on certain key ideas like is is pleasure
fundamentally the good or lack of pain
the good or is virtue the good yeah you
know you you're gonna have to you're not
gonna be able to just compromise on that
and still call it a a synthesis of the
two but there's nothing to say you can't
bring in elements of both Seneca is a
prime example of somebody who uses
epicurean insights in his letter to the
Laconia it's are sometimes called moral
letters and why does he do that because
look Ilyas himself is attracted to
epicureanism so he's using the language
and let the insights of the Epicureans
to attract him and further but oops says
my connection is unstable looks like we
might be having some internet issues
oh all right we're back it looks like we
had a little internet hiccup here
nothing we can do about that by the way
people always like complain I don't I
can't hear this or that well you know
it's the vast world of the
interconnected cables all right so back
to Epicureans and Stoics can you bring
them completely
together I mean the person who probably
does the most of that is is Seneca so I
would take a look at what he has to say
Spencer what would you say is the most
significant difference between the stoic
and Aristotelian conceptions of the good
life it's very simple
the stoic say that you know the things
that Aristotelian czar considering to be
lesser goods or not actually goods
they're merely preferred and difference
and the Aristotelian czar saying no
they're their goods and that would
include bodily health some degree of
wealth you know certain relationships
and stuff like that that's that's you
know that that's pretty straightforward
and again
Cicero's on the ends is the book to go
to for that I would say Epictetus does
have a few things to say about
Aristotelian 's calling them basically
just water you know just sort of better
off at the Kyrian's but I don't think
most stoical saw it that way all right
vol Durham I asked slots on dole box
political philosophy
I haven't read whole box since grad
school I don't remember much about him
so there's nothing really to say about
that Zen Thomas what is your favorite
play and William Shakespeare that is an
interesting question
it's been a while since I've watched the
Shakespeare play or read I used to I
used to read quite a few of his plays
because my dad left behind the complete
works of William Shakespeare in his
library and I took it with me everywhere
that I went and I really did enjoy it
quite a bit I don't know a favorite play
you know I'm gonna go bye-bye thinking
about film adaptations I remember here
in Milwaukee watching Hamlet at the
oriental theater with my mom a very long
performance that had an intermission and
everything and it was so well done so
well staged it was a quite a gorgeous
production
and you know it's a good play there's a
lot really going on in there so maybe
that's my favorite but I don't have a
lot of favorites of things these days
you know um all right let's see Jacob
says what about Christian public
intellectuals like Cornel West and Chris
Hedges they seem very helpful in our
political context when I think about
Cornel West I don't think about a
Christian intellectual I think about an
intellectual it might happen to be
Christian but I don't think that a lot
of his thought is coming out of being
Christian so I think you want to make a
distinction there and I mean West is is
useful I'm not
he used to be he was one of the people
like Richard Rorty when I was in grad
school everyone's like oh this guy's so
amazing and I they quickly lost their
shine for me they have some good
insights I don't think that they're
amazing like like people say and I think
they often have a lot of missteps I mean
if we want to say that that just being
Christian and taking Christianity
seriously in some respects makes a
person a public intellectual Alistair
McIntyre swung right and he's taken
quite a few stands so yeah I don't
really have that much more to say about
that
twice monk says loves the AMAs I enjoy
them to do do I have any thoughts on the
open letter to Harper magazine and the
whole debate about that I do indeed have
some and I'm only gonna give you a
thumbnail sketch because tomorrow for
and I haven't posted the event yet but I
will be soon we are going to have our
political theory and practice discussion
and it's going to be centered on the
notion of free speech which is a very
complicated notion anybody who's got
simplistic ideas about it is not going
to be happy with what I have said and
the the letter about cancel culture
again another complicated matter well
people always mean exactly the same
thing when they talk about Kim and in
canceled culture goes way back by the
way I remember I was
thing about this today when I was in so
either guy I'd finished graduate school
and I was teaching in my first job in
the prison and there was something about
Hillary Clinton being criticized for
something she'd said 20 years before so
this would have been in the early 2000s
and you know she'd her ideas on things
that evolved and I'm no fan of Clinton
by the way I actually actually didn't
like either one of them but I thought
that what was done was unfair which is
to go back 20 years and say you said
this at this point therefore you're you
have the same mentality about it in the
present and now that was happening in
the early 2000s before really any sort
of big internet like we've got now where
everything is so interconnected people
were already engaging in that sort of
gotcha stuff and conservatives by the
way I had actually put together a
database that would allow them to do
that back then some sort of dirty tricks
thing they kept track of like any
potential candidate what they would what
they would say you know a lot of these
were paper records so this this notion
of canceled cultures been around for a
while and I think we have to to
illuminate it a bit and explain what
canceling would be and who's more
subject to it and myself I'm a big
believer in consistency so if you're on
the right and you're gonna criticize
people on the left for their canceled
culture you'd better be policing your
own or you're full of crap and you're
just a partisan and the same thing goes
for the left if you're not calling out
your own for engaging in things that you
think are wrong that the right is doing
you're full of crap and you lose any any
legitimacy you know if we had something
like a big hook that could pull you off
the stage the way they used to do in
vaudeville shows that would be really
cool that would be a form of canceling
this so I'll have more to say about that
tomorrow I think I didn't say much about
free speech but I'll have plenty to say
about that tomorrow all right Isaac asks
where do you recommend someone should
start with the works of Nietzsche that's
a good question I
think that reading the birth of tragedy
is a good place to start it was his
first book he later criticized it but
there's still a lot in it that brings up
some you know classic Nietzsche and
themes and and I I think it's quite a an
excellent work by itself so I would
actually start there
some of his early essays would be worth
you know checking out as well if you're
if you like systematic stuff then the
genealogy of morals is you know a place
you want to go beyond good and evil is
also quite important I'm not one of
those people who thinks that the will to
power is like the key to Nietzsche's
thought I actually you know what I'm
teaching Nietzsche I'm usually teaching
Bertha tragedy the Spoke Zarathustra
genealogy of morals Beyond Good and Evil
and I think that you get enough good
nature stuff in there to to bring it up
Sassy's coming here to visit here we go
there's my little girl
see here 17 years old she's only 6 and
3/4 pounds now because she's lost so
much weight she she topped out I think
around 11 pounds or so when she was in
much better shape but you know for 17
years old going up and down the stairs
which for us would be like you know
climbing a small hill everyday pretty
good you know she's also got a great
appetite although she doesn't keep the
weight on sort of like what I was like
when I was a kid all right
sv any suggestions on philosophy books
for beginners I actually wrote an entire
blog piece about that which you can find
in my medium just go and you know look
for 10:10 philosophy books beginner
sadler google that and it'll it'll come
right up Aaron says I'm currently
studying the phenomenology of spirit I'm
not from a philosophy background are
there any techniques that you could
share that you use when you first begin
to dive in the dense works such as the
phenomenology I don't have
any techniques because generally the way
that I learned things doesn't map on to
well to how other people learn things
and you know I'll say this it's okay not
to grasp everything as you're reading
through dense works and it's okay to
proceed on you know without fully
understanding what you've gone through
and to go back and reread later you know
it's fine to read a book and to revisit
things and you don't want a place too
high of a stress on yourself to think
that you you totally under you know
totally understand everything that's not
the way philosophy works that's not even
the way that great novels work right so
I suppose that's all I'd really say mark
says you ever consider discussing any
African sci-fi writers in the worlds of
speculative fiction if you haven't
already seen the whole series yet Neddy
Okafor no I you know I don't know any
African sci-fi or fantasy or horror
weird authors but I'd be happy to expand
my my purview to them maybe you have
some good recommendations for me which
you know well when you have our our
talks you will bring that up but no you
know my my my reading is actually pretty
narrow I mean I started the world to
speculative fiction in part to give me
an opportunity to pursue I had read in
my childhood or teens or 20s and had
really enjoyed and I wanted to go back
and revisit and in most cases they
turned out to be pretty good you know
like reading Frank Herbert's dune or you
know Ursula Kayla greens Hamish novels
there were a few cases where I was like
yeah this didn't actually stand up like
Michael
[ __ ] Cornelius chronicles which I will
I just loved when I was a teenager and
in college I mean I some of my memories
are of like sitting in a hot house
without air conditioning on our couch
after having you know biked a whole lot
reading the Cornelius Chronicles eating
you know peaches or apricots and
listening to Van Halen in the background
and thinking this is amazing stuff right
and you know when I read through them
again it was not quite as impressed but
then you know I started taking
recommendations from other people and I
came across quite a few excellent
authors that way so I'd be happy to hear
about others as well what I'm gonna do
for this year is gonna be mostly like
authors that I've already got some sort
of background in so like you know we're
doing cordwainer Smith and and we're
gonna do
Miller's a canticle for Leibowitz we're
gonna do the stuff that we didn't get to
with our Scott backer on the second
apocalypse series but for next year it
could be quite good to do that all right
ash whare says stoicism says don't worry
about things you can't control one can't
control and Justice meted out by others
what does one do in that situation not
saying or doing anything makes me
complicit so that's a total
misunderstanding of stoicism you're
talking about the dichotomy of control
which doesn't say don't worry it says
first make the distinction properly and
then withdraw your desire and aversion
from that right and stoicism also that's
the only one principle of stoicism
stoicism is an interconnected system of
things the virtues also important in
stoicism right what's one of the virtues
justice and that requires you to act in
such a way as to try to not just be just
yourself but also to stand in the way of
injustice I mean this is this is not
hard to sort of like tease out and
figure out this is a big problem with
stoicism
or rather a truncated understanding of
stoicism that people get from blog posts
or sound bites or stuff like that it's a
total distortion and misunderstanding to
think that Stoics wouldn't actually
resist injustice we have historical
models right Cicero which was not a
stoic but influenced by them fought in
the Civil War his body Cato right
Epictetus teacher Missoni as Rufus was
exiled why criticizing the Emperor
standing up against injustice so this is
this is you know sort of a very common
misunderstanding about it and I've
written about this you can find some
some discussions of this in my blog or
xst know at TK or in things that have
been published and stoicism today and
there's many other people who talked
about this as well so you want to read
further in in stoic philosophy and that
will that will get good through that
Andrew why did religion replace
philosophy could it ever revert religion
didn't replace philosophy usually it was
the opposite where oh and maybe you're
thinking about like an ancient culture
religion never simply replaced
philosophy religion was always around
right and religion and philosophy are
often very closely interconnected with
each other so if you're thinking about
like you know 18th century and onward
reconstructions of the Middle Ages is
the age of faith which are usually just
you know propaganda for for you know
modern times basically the more that you
read about ancient and medieval
literature the more that'll wean you
away from those sorts of ideas people
were studying philosophy in the
monasteries and discussing it in the
universities and so in philosophy has
never been simply replaced by religion
as a matter of fact you know what we see
in modern times is for many people
philosophy replacing religion as
providing us with some sort of life
guidance right we have a large
proportion of nuns and that's why
there's a growing interest in things
like stoas
or neo Aristotelian ISM or you know
contemporary Epicureanism so read 52 why
do you think virtue ethics are not as
popular as dant illogical ethics in the
average person's ethical reasoning I
wouldn't say that that's actually the
case first of all there is no average
person there's plenty of average persons
and it really depends on what kind of
society you're looking at or what
culture you have in mind and virtue
ethics and dant illogical ethics are not
little you know sort of systems that are
floating out there with their axioms or
stuff like that they're always in body
this is something that McIntyre is very
good about stressing over and over and
over again ethics are always embodied in
social conditions and institutions and
they're transmitted that way that's what
gives them their substantive
characteristic and what you're probably
you know thinking of as virtue ethics
and des ontological approaches often
blur into each other you know prime
example of somebody who we classify as a
day on tala just in the history of
ethics but it was actually a lot of
virtue ethics stuff involved there as
well is the guy who wrote his
dissertation on Conte and then you know
translated Aristotle WT Ross so it's
it's it's not so simple as that you know
when we get to real systems of morality
they usually involve quite a bit and
virtue ethics one reason why it's so
appealing is because there are some kind
of base level notions that of you know
character traits and building up habits
and judging a person not just according
to the action but according to like sort
of the the overall character structure
motivational structure the you know that
that is something that you can get
people to buy into but you know both of
them require that we not read an
ontology can be parsed in a lot of
different ways it can just be well
there's rules and you gotta follow them
or it could be you know there's a
principle of human dignity and we ought
to respect that and it parses out like
this so I think we've got to be really
careful in using those sorts of terms
autodidact any
tips on how to read the confessions by
Augustin yes one thing right off the bat
if you're not into flowery religious
language just ignore all the prayers and
stuff like that you know or or look at
it almost like a anthropologist would
you know thinking about a foreign tribe
and what they what their ideas are and
that will help you out quite a bit
because there's an awful lot of oh my
lord and all that kind of stuff yeah if
that appeals to you okay get into that
but what you really want out of it is to
read the narrative and see the things
that he's going through and think about
the philosophical problems that he's
putting forth like what's the nature of
evil why did and that can be you know
related to his personal things what the
hell am i doing and picking these pears
and stealing them what is wrong with me
right that's that's the stuff I would
say to do Andrew says I've lost a lot of
people recently and become a little
scared and was just jumped a bit a
little scared of death where did that go
here we go not so much my own but the
impact on others what it leaves behind
any philosophical advice yeah I mean
this is one of those areas where you
know being connected with other people
does make us sort of extends our
vulnerability out into the world and on
this I don't really you know I don't
like I said before I'm an eclectic or a
pluralist I'm not a lot of people know
me from stoicism today so they assume
that I'm you know endorsing stoicism on
every single thing I don't actually buy
the stoic line on this I think that
there's something about being connected
with others you know I can follow
Epictetus advice that when I kiss my
wife or child remind myself that they're
mortal and I won't be up as a set when
they when they die and they're you know
he's not quite so cold as that because
he's saying those who you are you know
feeling affection to you know Phyllis
daughter gain in Greek it's already
assumed that there's affection there
we can to some degree and we probably
should minimize the irrational
vulnerability that living in a world in
which people die you know again this is
this cat right here she is gonna die and
she's gonna die either you know tomorrow
or next week or next month or next year
or maybe she'll live to 25 and then
she'll still go but she's gonna go you
know just trying to go right now
it's not really happy about being on
camera she's content to be in my arms
most of the time and you know I love
this cat but and I can extend her life
as we have already you know by giving
her a really great treatment and love
and wonderful food and she's got a
special diet oh that sort of thing and
we can make her her time as enjoyable as
a can be you know she gets catnip every
day she gets lots and lots of attention
but ultimately everybody dies and and
everybody that you know is either gonna
die before you or after you are at the
same time as you because the human
mortality rate is 100 percent so you
know what can what can you do about that
I would say you know realize that to
begin with realizing this is a
philosophical problem is is partly
helpful realizing that there is no
complete solution to it is is another
important aspect of it and then I'm
thinking about you know how do you want
to use the time that you do have with
others it can help put things into
perspective for you I think that's about
all I have to say on that although
that's that's probably worth doing like
a whole session about some time TM is
there a practical application for
self-study philosophy without a degree
yeah I mean on screwing up your life
right that's a very practical
application a lot of people are using
philosophical things from you know Plato
and Aristotle through the Stoics to you
know Christian thought existentialism to
make their lives a little bit less
full of contradictions and conflicts and
you could also apply it to your
relations to others studying philosophy
tends to make you better at like
understanding the assumptions that
you're making realizing when you're
about to make a dumb mistake doing
after-action reports for the dumb
mistakes that you've made putting things
in proper priority making distinctions
when they're needed you know there's all
sorts of very practical applications for
studying philosophy all right Spencer
asks here's an interesting question
which moral philosopher do you find to
be the most therapeutic if that's the
right word or at least beneficial from a
mental health perspective well you know
for me because I think that has to be
answered personally all right I would I
would probably say it is indeed
Epictetus although Aristotle provides so
much of a framework for me that's that's
useful Aristotle and later Aristotelian
zhh I mean there's other people who've
played a big role in my sort of thinking
out my own life and how it screwed up
and what to do about it
you know Blaise Pascal has played a
really important role mock Schaller
Maurice Blondell Gabrielle Marcel
they're they're quite important for me
but I think it's gonna vary from from
person to person and sometimes this is a
bit of a side note but this is worth
reflecting on so you know William James
I'm gonna fix my hair William James
makes this this point about temperament
and philosophers and he says that a lot
of whom gravitate to is a matter of
things that are we can call it
temperament we can call it our
volitional nature as he does in the will
to believe and there aren't like super
great convince everybody rational
reasons for that but we don't have to
have those and I think a lot of times
people doing philosophy feel like if
they if their solution can't convince
everybody else or if it can't be the
one-size-fits-all for everybody but it's
no good but a lot of philosophizing and
incorporating philosophy into your life
a lot of doing philosophy as a way of
life is figure who actually you can have
as useful interlocutors all right Jake
what's my thoughts on Richard Rorty
again like Cornel West interesting
person they were really talked up so
much when I was in graduate school that
when I did go to read their stuff I was
like yeah this is good but you know not
great not somebody who I want to like
you know Center my studies around some
interesting insights
I like that Rory is pretty
straightforward about his his
commitments so I think that's kind of a
good trait but you know I don't think
he's going to be an important
philosopher for the future then again I
could be wrong right
Michael Ray do I think America is on the
verge of another revolution will it be
socialist fascist or something else I
don't think it'll be socialist or
fascist unless you know in the one case
some some useful developments happen
around the other case some major crisis
happens and throws us into a dystopia I
mean we're already pretty dystopia
as it is we're just not in like a
across-the-board dystopia things suck
for so many Americans in so many screwed
up ways that don't have to be that way
think about our we you know I've said
this so many times we don't have a
health care system we have interlocking
systems most of which are done for
profit not for the good of those who are
actually being dealt with in them and we
have two political parties one
which is like at this point totally
corrupt that's the Republicans and you
know filled with with just nutters at
this point the other of which was about
halfway corrupt and often gets in its
own way and that's the Democrats and
sometimes things go back and forth you
know we don't have any effective third
parties you know I mean we have third
parties but they they have zero
influence on anything other than when
they you know people who are attracted
to them get a ton of money and then like
spend it to try to steer one of the main
things the other way like the Koch
brothers have done with libertarianism
and Republicans I think we are in the
midst of a sea change when it comes to
protests black lives matters and a
number of other things and I think that
a lot of factors like like the total
mismanagement of COBIT by most
government agents in this case
contributed to it I think the screwed up
health care system that we have
I think the screwed up economy that we
have have you know not just fallen on
people and made them be like what the
garbage right but there's a lot of other
people who were a bit more comfortable
and could like say wow this is bad but
it's it's you know could be worse and
they you know they saw for example being
people being brutalized on videos though
and a certain point a lot of people and
I know this happened to myself were like
Jesus enough is enough
this is just insane what's what we've
allowed to go on things you have to
start being rolled back and I think that
what we're going to see it's not going
to be so much a socialist but a
progressive and it's not gonna be a
revolution but it's gonna be like push
push push push push you know and there's
gonna be a lot of setbacks and a lot of
backlash but I do think that those who
are interested in unscrewing things up
for the ordinary person not just for you
know elites and there are elites on the
Republican and Democrat side one of the
tragedies of the Republicans is seeing
all these people who are just screwed
over and over
again by their own party and its
ideology suffering from it in red states
and not able to get out of there
you know seeing that because there to to
devote it to buying into some some
narrative the same thing does happen
also the one could point out in Democrat
run cities like here in Milwaukee right
but I think there is going to be I think
there's gonna be some changes ahead
because they thought he would accelerate
some sort of process maybe they turned
out to be right because you look at the
[ __ ] show that is this administration
and you know what the local gops are
doing like here in Wisconsin for example
or down in Florida
and you're like holy crap this this
stuff this crap came on I don't know o
TM says even that you're reading a lot
do you usually read it physical
electronica or audio form I read in
physical form I like books if I'm taking
a long drive I can listen to audio books
but otherwise I don't generally do that
Andrew why didn't Seneca speak of
epictetus but had very similar content
lack or disrespect ignorance
why would Seneca know anything about
Epictetus you know Epictetus wouldn't
have been on his radar it's more the
opposite direction Seneca was an advisor
to Nero
Epictetus is owner was Nero secretary so
Seneca FF Alfred etus would have known
each other but that doesn't mean that
Epictetus would have known Seneca
personally or that Seneca would have
noticed anything about epictetus it is
interesting that Seneca also doesn't
reference same estonia's Rufus who was
quite important in that time as well all
right RT asks if a philosophers in
morale does it reduce the credibility of
their philosophical works concerning
morality yeah I mean I think there's
actually you know if you think about the
sexual abuse scandals with somebody like
Thomas Pogo I don't I don't know that
polkas philosophy is really that good
anyway you know it's more like well
analytic people loved him and thought he
made some good points and he turned out
to be a complete degenerate you know but
yeah if you find out that somebody is
not practicing what they preach I think
that that makes a huge impact on people
it creates what we call scandal all
right a stumbling-block scandal that's
that's what's what scandal actually
means right so yeah I think that's
that's that's safe to say
Reid James asks if I've read the cave
and light by Herman I have not if you
want me to read it then it could be good
to send me a copy and I only read
physical copies I don't read PDFs for a
long time this is a separate topic is
that people like talk about Nick land
and I'd be like heaven Red Fang Newman
ah you want to send me a copy then
finally somebody did and they sent me a
PDF and I was like buddy I don't I don't
want a PDF if you're gonna you know if
you if you want me to like talk about
something just put a friggin book in my
hand and I'll I'll do it all right Ben
thank you for your lectures what are
your thoughts on the famous Japanese
swordsman Miyamoto Musashi in his life
philosophies I haven't read any of that
stuff since I was a kid interested in
martial arts back in my teens so III you
know the book of five rings I don't know
I don't even really remember anything
from it aunty gaya are you a fan of any
of Dennis Johnson's books
I don't know Dennis Johnson the only
dentist Johnson that I actually do
remember was a guy who I taught in
prison he was a nice guy too by the way
very very thoughtful read fifty-two have
you ever watched Andrei Rublev what do
you think of its religious themes I have
not I have not watched that that
particular tartar tartar ski movie the
only thing I think I've actually watched
by him as the stalker which I thought
was amazing
so maybe I'd be inclined to watch it but
I you know I probably should watch a lot
more movies I don't watch a lot more
good ones
Kevin thoughts on the so-called
metaphysical versus non meta physical
interpretations of Hegel I've read that
some scholars see Hegel is close to
Cantwell they see him as deeply
metaphysical Conte is metaphysical
consciousness is a meta physician who's
criticizing metaphysics but he has a
metaphysics I mean the groundwork for
the metaphysics of morals right there is
a metaphysics of morals I don't I don't
actually know what's what's being
referred to as metaphysical versus non
meta physical interpretations of Hegel I
don't read a lot of secondary literature
these days you know frankly it's enough
for me to like just keep digging into
the primary text and I want to get my
angle more or less straight so I'm not
I'm not a great commentator on that
Stewart are you a fan of Atlas luckily
chuckle ease work have you read much it
is I actually did one of the worlds of
speculative fiction series on his works
not a real fan of Huxley because I'm you
know I'm not a big believer in and like
opening up you know your mind through
drugs or stuff like that I don't I like
the people who criticized him many of
them were you know you know religious
people were practicing meditation think
that you can't you can't effectively use
drugs as a shortcut for things I think
he's an interesting fiction writer his
fiction is kind of boring to read in
terms of like character and dialogue and
plot but it it's a lot of cool ideas
that he's working with I don't get
anybody beats Huxley just for his file
bozo any thoughts on ggx idea of
Christian atheism the only way to real
atheism is through Christianity and you
got that from Lacan like I actually
thought that so you know I just go to
the source and read Lacan on those
matters
Michel raid baby-boomers destroyed
themselves
I don't know that that's the case
there's there's still a lot of them
around and they still control a lot of
things and they certainly if they
destroyed themselves they certainly did
more damage to my generation to
generation Y and generation Z than they
did to themselves I would say and they
also you know they also allowed a lot of
stuff to happen on their watch that
previous generations managed to screw up
as well um all right Andre Russian nice
simple question what is reality you know
the stuff that is and the stuff that
that stays there whether we like it or
not is often one of the ways that it's
it's discussed all right Daniel Stanton
are you familiar with or have you
engaged with the philosophy for children
movement yeah I've known I've known some
people that are involved in like Plato
which is an organization for it I don't
really do it that much you know as a
matter of fact I could say I hardly do
it at all right people sometimes do use
my videos for it but I don't I don't do
a lot of engagement of people who are
non adults you know younger than
college-age I think it's a perfectly
legitimate thing to do by the way some
of my videos are used as resources in
like the Portuguese national curricula
and things like that where they actually
teach philosophy but I don't I don't do
a lot of that bruce says hello I'm glad
to see Bruce here and let's see what we
got next Andrew I think stoic virtues
have been radically under played in
society how do we bring them to the
forefront
I mean by bringing him to the forefront
by talking about them more than just the
dichotomy of control that that's that's
a pretty straightforward one I mean you
could also talk about practicing the
virtues and then when people say why are
you doing this good thing it's a well
I'm stoic and you know temperance is a
virtue or courage is a virtue or justice
is a virtue all right Alexander McKee
what is some of your favorite media is
there any fiction in part
you hold as ideologically or
philosophically profound lots of it I
mean that's why I started the worlds of
speculative fiction series because
there's all these great philosophical
themes the one that I'm going to talk
about this month cordwainer Smith really
interesting guy and his instrumentality
of mankind narrative world is full of
like some really profound reflections on
human existence and where we're going as
a species and what drives us and
inequality and you know what makes us
human
so ok dick another great example Ursula
K Le Guin and we could go on and on and
on somebody else who I particularly like
is creator Doris Dostoevsky
alright a lot of the people that fit
into the classic existentialist spectrum
Kafka Rilke you know they're they're
they're really good de Beauvoir all
right Isaac Johnson any books I would
recommend for an introduction the
philosophy of music dad I can't say much
about it's not really an area of mine
although I have an interest in how they
come together but there is like a field
philosophy of music and I don't I don't
really know that much about about that
field per se so Eric says our
mathematical axioms universally true
axioms would be the things that you take
as being true so they're not like
demonstrated there are the things that
you demonstrate from are they
universally true I mean what do you mean
does everyone accept them no is there
something to them probably so yeah Marc
Lord what do you think is the general
effect of market ideology when it is
used as a source of moral authority well
that's a good one so yeah there's a lot
of people especially here in the United
States where we're really enamored of
like free market solutions that never
turned out to be free market by the way
it's always some crony capitalism where
somebody who knows
the person in charge gets their firm to
be hired you know the the idea of like
we're getting an open free market it's
almost always an illusion and it's
always a cover-up for some [ __ ] that
somebody's about to pull and there are
some things that should not be turned
into market commodities and there are
some other things that should not be
made simply permeable through
deregulation to finance capital you know
the idea that that hospital groups are
actually owned by by you know firms that
specialize in portfolios terrible idea
you know we should have so many levels
of separation we should have so many
things that are not merely subject to
the market Sandell is a really good book
about this by the way and I don't
remember the exact title but it's like
you know what it's it's about what
shouldn't be just subject to the to the
marketplace and you know it tends to
pervade all sorts of other areas as well
so I remember when I was in religious
studies doing a lot of work in in that
field as well as in philosophy a lot of
the contemporary literature would talk
about denominations and their market
share and there were all these pastors
and other people who are like we need to
bring people into our church let's
figure out a marketing campaign for that
we need to be like wow this is really
getting you know this is really getting
away from what your institution is
supposed to be about after a certain
point it gets it gets more marketing
than actual whatever whatever else
you're doing and there's there's other
institutions that that simply should not
be turned over to the market as well and
that are thoroughly permeated like our
prison system you know we shouldn't have
private prisons we also shouldn't be if
we're gonna make prisoners work in
usually substandard conditions we should
probably pay them more than 25 cents an
hour and OSHA should be in there you
know there's there's so many things like
that I would say well we've really made
takes alright looks like it skipped up a
bit so I got a scroll there we go
Gottfried says what is the ontology of
the Hegelian Geist as Hegel think
there's an existence spirit behind
something like esprit de corps if so is
it empirical in a hyper or onion of
sorts I don't know what that that's
supposed to be
is it empirical yeah it's partly
empirical but it's it's also not
empirical I mean it's not as if
everything is everything shows all of
its sides and our experience all at once
Hado thinks that spirit does externalize
itself it goes from you know the realm
of likes a mere ideas or sentiments and
does things in the world it becomes veer
click it becomes actual alright
is there an ontology and Miguel Ian
Geist I don't know that there's an
actual like ontology in the sense of
some sort of systematic presentation I
think that way you got to do is like
look at his works and see what he has to
say about it and then think about how it
how it plays itself out you know Daniel
Pasteur did did I read Jordan Peterson
I read enough of maps of meaning to say
wow this is pretty you know wild stuff
and and it was very funny to see him
attacking post-modernism later on
because that's a pretty postmodern Burt
book I haven't read his rules book I
read you know excerpts from it enough to
say yeah I don't don't want to bother
with this it's it's I don't find him a
particularly insightful or interesting
person and I think 15 years from now
people are gonna be like Jordan who
because we've got lots and lots and lots
of figures like that throughout the
history of ideas
um ecwid Vic and Stein a philosophical
Philistine or the greatest philosophical
Philistine so a Philistine is some
whose uncultured right but still has
opinions on things and Vick ensign
definitely would have benefited by wider
reading in philosophy and better
engagement with the contemporary
philosophy of this time I think the
concern is very interesting but he did a
lot of reinventing of wheels
particularly in you know discussion of
language that we're already there in
other thinkers this notion that language
is not just about you know
referentiality and stuff like that but
about the use I mean it's not as if they
haven't known that for a long time
before he formulated it I mean I think
he's got some interesting contributions
to make but I I don't think in the end
we're gonna look at him as a first-rate
philosopher there was kind of a cult
that was built up around him all right
nin NIT tonneaus asks can I recommend
movies if there are any recording to
Lacan Ian's thoughts I mean nothing
really comes to mind is particularly
Lacan Ian there are a lot of like film
critics who do a sort of like dumb down
version of Lacan and then apply it to
like Hitchcock and stuff like that but
you know their their work isn't very
good I thought that it's really like
karate and space-time do you have any
opinions and artificial intelligence and
how it might change philosophy my my gut
feeling is that artificial intelligence
and machine learning are very
metaphorical concepts and that we don't
have anything remotely like what we're
capable of I think that you know there's
already ways in which philosophy has
been significantly changed by things
that we call artificial intelligence
think about how search engines work and
what gets boosted up to the top in in
recommended articles or something like
in Google Scholar or you know
academia.edu or stuff like that that's
involving a kind of low low grade
I write there's algorithms I don't think
that I mean I could be wrong about this
I don't see AI is able to engage in
high-level philosophical discourse
primarily because I don't I don't see
them as being able to understand what's
being discussed I think and I've been
saying this really since I've got a
friend who's very interested in AI and
he started his own computer company
thirty years ago and he and I have been
having discussions about this back and
forth ever since I view AI less as
something that exists on its own and
more something that intermediates
between humans and other humans or
humans and themselves and so I mean
that's something that I think probably
needs to need to say a lot more about
that but I won't do that at this point
in time but err Guerlain says can I help
breakdown levy NASA's idea of ethics
precedes existence it's been a while
since I've read loving us and that
sounds like sort of a parody of sorts
you know existence precedes essence I'll
say this for loving us ethics is first
philosophy we are in a relation to the
other prior to anything else and we can
hide that from ourselves we can you know
we can abstract from it and try to
reduce it down to a set of rules or
something more manageable but we're
always caught in in this responsibility
to others that we can never fully meet
that that is probably what he means by
that I'm guessing so alright um let's
see where were we
there dad a row was a question about
Socrates in the apology I discussed this
dismisses and eggs a grist for saying
the Sun and Moon we're not gods do you
try to disguise his atheism to avoid
conviction or was itwas anti science so
there wasn't a science back then so
that's not being anti science
he doesn't dismiss an exam
as such he just says listen I'm not an
exact or trying to prosecute him you can
find his Scrolls for sale over there
I mean Socrates Socrates isn't an
atheist it's pretty clear from reading
the the other dialogues that he does
believe in something but it's a very
different conception of God yeah butter
Guerlain has a follow-up does that mean
empathy and treating the other fairly
comes before understanding itself it's
more like understanding yourself
shouldn't be an impediment to and it
sounded so much about empathizing with
the other for Lebanon it's about doing
justice to the other you know protecting
them doing giving what one ought to do
maybe the other doesn't even like care
about you at all or or relate to you but
ethics should always be placed first
according to loving us and it should
never be taken out of the picture so if
you're on so here's a great example of
this if your understanding of yourself
is of like you know the typical say
middle-class American who has a
comfortable existence has a job goes to
work you know does those their duties to
the people connected with them but isn't
particularly concerned about the beggar
on the street or what's happening in you
know in the rest of society in part
because you can you can afford to kind
of float on this surface where
everything is OK in your neighborhood
and even though if you walk down the
street and you went into people's homes
you'd find people you know crying at
random intervals or you know abusing
each other things like that living that
sort of existence is in Levy NASA's view
betraying the other you know it's
betraying what what ethics requires of
us and for it for letting us you can
never really completely do justice to
the other this is one of the things I
find problematic about Latinos and
especially about Levin a CI ends 11 se
ends are like their own kind of
weird group where they're all like bye
moaning constantly that uh we can't do
justice to the other did the other
people who encounter them say similar
sorts of things as well all right so so
wada i'm a first year medical student in
india I'm interested in philosophy
particularly that relating to science
where can I start book recommendations I
always say start with Plato
you know you don't have to become a
Platon us but the dialogues are well
worth reading not because they'll give
you an answer to everything but because
they'll open up all sorts of important
questions and Plato is so massively
influential and everybody else that it's
if he's a really good place to start
with Neil asks how important was your
proposal to your thesis or any writing
at grad school so you're talking about
like the master's thesis and the PhD
dissertation how important was the
proposal it was pretty important to put
a proposal together it's like one of the
steps that you have to go through and
then you have a committee and they give
you feedback on that they're usually
like well I like this part I don't like
this part fix this and this and you know
interestingly in my PhD proposal session
we radically revised my project I came
in with the intention of writing a
dissertation on Hegel and Maurice
Blondell with some Marx and Kierkegaard
in the middle part and I left that room
being told I should concentrate totally
on Blondell especially I'm as
untranslated works at the time so you
know my proposal wasn't what I actually
did I think for a lot of people the the
proposal is it winds up being pretty
close to what they're actually doing to
do most people also pick more manageable
projects than I typically took if
in in retrospect I should have written
on something easy that I could turn into
a book and published instead I wrote
this this very unmanageable mess of
things so justice why is there any
thoughts on who Cyril is there anything
you like from him yeah there's some
things I will say a lot of time Swiss
roll is kind of boring to read but he is
he is useful when I teach him I usually
have people read his article on
phenomenology the Cartesian meditations
and then sometimes I'll do that like the
crisis stuff but I'm not usually
teaching the the hardcore let's do these
analyses in depth
dad said I actually wrote my master's
thesis on Israel at that time at
Southern Illinois University
Anthony Steinbach it was my master's
thesis adviser was translating the
passive synthesis manuscripts and we
like did an entire class on it and I you
know I liked what I was seeing in those
and so I wrote on that and the
constitution of language wound up
bringing in disel sir and in effect
replicating dairy does speech and
phenomena as I read it later I was like
oh crap
pretty much everything that I did in my
my master's thesis has been done here
better by Derrida but I mean which was
interesting little scholar z' tend to be
kind of a small group and they often are
kind of you know they're they're the
best way to describe him is kind of
nerdy types they get really into like
this and they they want those usually
know some stuff outside of Husserl but
they really really really want to talk
about Husserl and you know there's
nothing wrong with that more power to
them you know all right
uh let's see Andrew has there ever been
a philosopher
who's sort of a bumbling mess that scene
is very intellectual but his works were
brilliant
that's a good question I'm sure there
have been quite a few like that
and and I mean I would imagine that some
of them would be people who we
recognized later on as like oh they were
really good but nobody else recognized
it at the time do I know anybody like
that I mean you know quite a few of the
the people who I know personally who are
philosophers academic philosophers and
who write brilliant stuff often don't
have the best social skills and hang out
with them at conferences and you know
you're watching them like engage with a
bartender and you're like wow this this
person you know they're not doing
anything bad but they're certainly not
the person that you would like have
organized a party or something like that
right so I guess there's something like
that but nobody nobody particularly
comes to mind but it's a very funny
question
all right balázs have you heard of
nicola and acceleration ISM yeah I
talked about that a little bit earlier
you know people are always telling me
about Nick land and if somebody wants to
send me Fang newman ah I'll read it but
otherwise I'm happy just with the
summaries that I've seen of it twice
says yeah I can't thanks for the
thoughtful answer don't cancel okay yeah
I'll be doing that tomorrow eh how do
you go about writing a paper research
thoroughly before writing and writing
and researching at the same time outline
first okay so that's a good question
and there is no like Universal way to do
it for me a lot of the time at this
point in my career I am relying on a a
good bit of like research I've already
done in the past and I'm gonna go back
to the texts and dig around a bit but I
usually know what it is that I want and
sometimes I'll say okay I need to see
what the what other people are saying
about this and look at the secondary
literature sometimes I won't you know
when I was a graduate student I used to
like write in these I'd write papers in
these sessions where I have my computer
I would sit on the floor I had my
computer set up it was a big
thing not like these nice laptops that
we have now and back then I was a heavy
smoker so I would either be I'd have
like packs of cigarettes or I'd have my
own you know drum usually and roll my
own cigarettes and I'd roll up a bunch
of cigarettes and then I'd have my pot
of coffee and I would start around like
noon or so and I'd have all my books and
articles you know photocopied stuff
piled up around me and I have a general
idea of what it was that I was going to
do and I'd have been doing research
leading up to that and then I would do
this massive paper writing thing that
could last anywhere from you know six
hours to a day and I would just keep
making more coffee smoking cigarettes
thinking about stuff writing stuff
rewriting stuff and at the end of it I'd
have a paper and then I would crash for
a day or two yeah
that is not something I'd recommend it's
not a great way to do things
so James Frank Herbert or Isaac Asimov
if I had to pick between the two hands
down Frank Herbert Eric Larsen what
defect is a deconstructionist like
Derrida oda Heidegger I guess some but
you could you could do I mean
deconstruction hasn't just been done by
Derrida I have an article that I wrote a
long time ago showing that Maurice
blown-down who you know wrote accion
1893 in 1893 long before Heidegger was
publishing let alone Derrida his method
of imminence does something like what
what Derrida is calling deconstruction
so you know um Matt Henderson have I
ever experienced any conflict between my
vocation as a teacher of philosophy and
my religious beliefs are there any
philosophers you could recommend who
written about this I don't know I don't
know that there are I'm sure there's
some people who have talked about it but
I don't know who they'd be it's less
about like what content I would teach
because I think it's important to you
know teach what's out there regardless
of what my religious beliefs happen to
be
and do so faithfully and you know say I
think this parts right and this parts
wrong I would say that in the profession
of teaching there's a lot of stuff not
directly related to the classroom and
more related to all the other stuff
around the classroom you know
participating in an academic institution
where you're like well this is [ __ ]
man this sucks
so you know prime example of this is you
know I teach from Marquette University
which is ostensibly a Catholic and
specifically Jesuit school and the way
that Marquette treats its students and
its staff and a lot of its professors is
as far removed from Christian social
teachings as you could possibly get and
you know being there you see a lot of
things go on that that shouldn't be
going on and that you know I find that
upsetting but that doesn't keep me from
from doing what I'm what I'm doing
faithful ball are you a real doctor
yeah because there's different senses of
doctor right there's medical doctor
which I'm not and then there's PhD which
entitles you to be called doctor because
Doctor of Philosophy yeah and if you if
you you know people sometimes get worked
up about that only medical people should
be called doctors okay well you know see
how see how far that'll get you and then
you know see whether any academic person
ever wants to cooperate with you right
all right we're getting close to the end
of our time so I'm gonna I'm gonna jump
around a bit and start picking some
stuff just to see what we have in all of
this I won't be able to get to
everybody's questions but that is the
way it always works here here's a good
one from read do I know of any good
theories on how to manage other people
ethically and effectively I'm on track
to become management and my engineering
firm and want to do my duties well yeah
there's an entire literature out there
about that but you know it's there's no
one single book I can recommend what I
would say is you want to do two things
you want to look at the literature
that's out there about leadership and
management and look for stuff that
actually has some philosophical basis to
it so it's not just people regurgitating
the same ideas and calling them slightly
different things over and over again so
you want to do that you also want to
spend some time reading philosophers who
actually talked about not management as
such but talk about human organizations
and the good life and communities and
stuff like that so like Aristotle is a
prime example I when I'm working with
corporate clients I'm often bringing in
ideas from Aristotle and I don't tell
them that they're coming from Aristotle
because then they might not be as
receptive to them but if they come in
afterwards and they say where did you
get these ideas from I'm like Aristotle
Nick and McCain ethics such-and-such or
politics book such-and-such a rhetoric
book such-and-such you know so I would
say read both of those and then you know
some of the emotional intelligence
literature is as useful don't buy into
like their whole program but I think
that there's something something quite
quite nice to that and you know it's
interesting you're gonna find when you
open up the book emotional intelligence
it begins with a quote from Aristotle
right so that's that's worth checking
out
retro gamer says how's the Maurice blown
dal epub coming along there isn't any
epub coming along I would have to go
back to you might be referring to Patri
amante which I you know did a
translation of way back in the day and
would have to go back to and revise and
all of that it's probably in WordPerfect
form rather than word form I haven't
done anything on that recently and I
also would have to track down in my
collected papers my photocopy of pottery
am on eat a right now I'm in the midst
of teaching three online classes as well
as generating a lot of content and
getting ready for the fall and
I'm going to be teaching a lot of online
classes as well so I don't have too many
writing things coming along at this
point in time let's see here
well it's my stomach can't wait to eat
Michael Frank you said you don't believe
show up an hour was a top-tier
philosopher can explain why you say that
what separates the top tier philosophers
from the second-tier philosophers no one
single thing just a whole bunch of
different factors I mean I think he's
sort of high second here I just don't
think that his ideas are as important as
those of some of his near contemporaries
like contour Hegel or nature you know I
think Nietzsche if I have to pick
between Nietzsche's show up an hour I'll
take Nietzsche other people might have
different rating systems you know
Schopenhauer said somewhat of a
renaissance lately which is always nice
because he serves to be studied but it's
you know it's ultimately gonna be sort
of the sort of kind of thing where
somebody who spent a lot of time within
the field is gonna make what appears
from the outside like a purely
subjective judgment but probably has a
whole bunch of different bases to it you
know I'd have to think about it a bit
more nausea at what point does the night
of faith hear you talking about
Kierkegaard become the night of infinite
resignation in Kierkegaard never there
are two distinct things as a matter of
fact you have to be the knight of
infinite resignation before you can be
the knight of faith he seems to suggest
I don't know that he's completely
correct about that but I don't know why
you would go backwards with that right
so the sophist is Plato's story of the
cave a comment on class Lavery or
ideological attachment it's more about
ideology than class flavor he's not I
mean the people that are just sitting
there in the cave they're not
manufacturing stuff right they're not
the lower class in that sense of being
the ones who have to labor as a matter
of fact the only
they're doing anything are the people
behind them or doing the puppet shows
for their their their amusement and
interest so it's I think it's much more
about being captivated by some sort of
mindset and not realizing that the stuff
you're being presented with is not the
true story that you have to then the
other part that's really important in
this story is that you have to be
dragged up into the light and then it
takes you a while to acclimate yourself
to seeing the reality Watergate how is
it possible they have a social democracy
without high spending and taxes probably
isn't but that's not a reason not to
have it I mean we spend our high
spending right now on the military which
is a really piss-poor investment and we
spend it on all sorts of frivolous
[ __ ] as well you know think about
the PPP loans that went to all these
cronies yeah and then you know the idea
about the the little bit of safety net
that we did is these twelve hundred
dollars or less checks going to people
and and many people haven't even seen
them yet you know it's not a question of
whether you have spending it's a
question of what you spend it on and
it's not a question of whether you tax I
mean we've had high taxes in the past
and there's nothing intrinsically bad
about it you know I for example think
that that you know compared to how it
used to be decades ago the elite in our
you know our our society paid just a
miniscule amount of tax and try to evade
it wherever they can
so nausea but so what degree do you
think Kierkegaard ripped off Pascal I
don't think he ripped off Paschal but he
does mention Pascal in some of his works
like the philosophical fragments so I
would say rather it's it's that he's
working with similar themes that are
well worth exploring
groove s thoughts on contemporary
architecture I don't really have an
awful lot I will say that the stuff that
I see here going up in Milwaukee where I
live over the last 15 years is pretty
schlocky you know we go and I'm talking
about like apartment buildings and you
know storefronts and stuff like that
I think that we've had some really
crappy design stuff for the last 20
minutes
so I'm not a big fan of that stuff let's
see here Gil Gil gosh do I plan to go
over the legal fought the philosophy of
Becker AIA
in a future video he was very
influential in the philosophy of the
founders it was somewhat influenced I
wouldn't say super influential yet maybe
down the line if I ever do something
specifically on punishment but there's
so many other thinkers that I need to
get to before doing that you know I mean
we mentioned show up an hour earlier and
I do need to treat some stuff on
Schopenhauer right I'm working on some
stuff on Hume right now most of what I
produce tends to be in light of what I'm
teaching in my classes so you know if I
were to teach a class specifically on
philosophy of punishment then it would
make a lot of sense let's see here Eric
are you
reductionist meaning that all societal
struggle is rooted in economic class I
mean I think you could easily watch the
stuff that I've done for you know
on YouTube for years and years and years
and probably answer your own question
but the answer is no class is something
that really is important but it's one
thing among many other things as well so
let's see what can I go out on because
we're at one minute before I end and
then I got to eat and then do another
thing to do to do here's a good one is
freewill a reality or a philosophical
fantasy as sam Harris suggests I don't
know do you do you feel like you have to
accept what Sam here suggests or do you
have any choice about it yourself when
you're not you're not going to get away
from freewill we freewill is is often
dismissed or are you gated against
because somebody will come up with a
straw man for what freewill and people
believing in freewill is supposed to be
it's clear we do make some choices it's
also clear too by the way that a lot of
the you know scientific literature about
like brain states and all that has been
really overblown is really pseudoscience
there are some things that you know
we're where we come up with rational is
rationalizations afterwards but that
doesn't mean that there isn't any part
of us freely deciding I think what we
have to do is clarify what we mean by
free will and you know I think you're
kind of stuck with the idea if you think
you're truly determined well then you
know it must be interesting to have
conversations with you about how your
decision working process goes so that's
a good thing to end on I didn't get to
everybody's but I get to most people's
questions and comments and we'll pick
this up again you know next month I do
have another event coming up tomorrow
that I'll be posting about later today
once I get some some other things off my
plate and I think
for your questions and comments and I'm
going to end it right here